one critical position out of three
different Sicilians where you get chance
to sacrifice your peace and get a
winning position at just opening stage
sounds very interesting right
welcome guys as in today's lecture you
are going to witness
some cool tricks in the Sicilian French
variation thank you
let's start with how we can achieve our
desired position out of three different
Sicilians
so number one if you are open Sicilian
player then there are two ways black can
enter into our tricky territory number
one E6
Knight to C3 and A6 the Sicilian French
radiation which is very popular at all
level of chairs
here my recommendation is you start with
G3 allowing black to grab the space on
the queen side
but the big time point is after Bishop
to G2 Bishop to B7
nope we are not looking at the move D3
and a close Sicilian setup but rather we
are playing like a more open Sicilian
with our thematic break D4
after Pawn takes and Knight takes
black really don't want to play E5 now
as our Knight can jump to their five
square so
one of the frequent Choice from the
black is to play D6 getting the control
of the E5 square and ready to play in
Knight to F6
whereupon we can castle and after Knight
to F6 which has a clear threat of
pushing the pawn on B4 and getting the E
Pawn white simply defended with Rook to
even where we have reached to the
critical position
okay let me show you the second
alternative black can start with the D6
structural and after our Knight to C3
Knight F6 doesn't make sense here as
after E5 white enter into the Caris
variation which is quite annoying for
the black player so many educated Master
player here continue with A6 whereupon
you guessed it
yup G3 B5 Bishop to G2 Bishop to B7 and
now D4 our trademark break in the center
and after C takes D4 Knight takes D4 it
doesn't matter here whether black
continue with E6 or Knight to F6 let's
say E6
Castle Knight to F6 simple thread we
defined with rook and guess what yup we
reach to the exact same position
last but not least if you are a knight
to C3 player here then you can also
reach to a desired position via this
model E6 G3
A6 Bishop to G2
B5
Knight G to E2 Bishop to B7
and now rather than playing the move D3
I recommend you go ahead with D4 so that
after C captures D4 Knight captures D4
D6
Castle Knight to F6 and Rook to even no
wonder we again reach to our critical
position
now just for a moment take a pause and
look at the database well in the
majority of the cases black has tried
these three options and I can't tell you
all of them are disaster
yup you heard it right so let's see each
by turn and find out
how white can get straight away winning
advantage against each of them
number one Bishop to E7 a very bad
choice and the simplest repetition start
with
E5 a double attack so that after Bishop
takes G2
you indeed take the night keeping our
double attack theme and here by force
black is losing a piece
so the bass black can do over here is
Bishop takes F6 but after King takes G2
quite clearly emerge with a piece up
the second move I want to consider is
Knight B to D7
and against this no wonder our thematic
break if I works like a child
after Bishop captures G2 and E captures
F6 it doesn't matter wherever this
bishop run away our next Target is very
obvious
yup you guessed it from the arrows we
want to sacrifice on E6 so that black
position completely collapse at the
opening stage
well black Bishop has two good locations
number one let's say black player is a
smart guy and he identify the threat so
he continued with Bishop to H3
but I'm afraid this is not going to be
enough as white has this nice sequence
Queen to H5 check attacking the bishop
this poor Bishop has no way to hide as
after Bishop to F5 white can simply Chop
It Off so black has to go for the
counter-attacking move Queen to F6 but
then what can easily defend this Knight
with Bishop to E3 and now black has the
only move in this position namely Bishop
to F5
whereupon we deliver this nice
surprising package
just look at this guys
night to defy
what a move
and the problem is black can't take this
Knight in the view of Bishop to G5 and
bye bye black sweetie
so that is right out of the equation
so that means black has to sadly
retrieve the queen back to the d8 square
where white initiative continue on the
board with this lovely attacking move
Bishop to G5
well you can't block with the pawn or
the bishop
so the only logical response exists here
is G6 and in fact I reached to this
position recently against a 20 200 feet
a rated player and you will be amazed
how quickly game has been finished
I responded with Queen to H4 my opponent
moved the queen out
only to find the root shock
Knight takes F5 G takes F5 and now this
decisive preparation move Rook takes E6
with shattered all the black hole
there is a force made guys and black
cannot avoid as after Pawn takes E6 and
the move Queen to H5 we have a
picturesque checkmate at just 19th move
of the game
now if you look at the database in the
majority of the cases Bishop to B7 has
been highestly played here which
completely ignore what white wants to do
and in fact some strong players
including X World Championship
Challenger nepom Nishi fall for this
where white has this dazzling sacrifice
yup you got it
Knight captures E6
ready for the Discovery Channel so black
has to take it
now you play this nice intermediate move
Pawn takes G7
Bishop takes G7 and finally when white
delivered this check I think game is
almost gone
it doesn't matter wherever the King goes
our next Target is very simple Rook text
D6 taking the piece back with the
interest where black king is roaming all
around the board
no black can't play Bishop to C8 in the
view of simple threat Queen to D5 and
the bye bye rook in the corner
so that is right out of the equation
probably the only accurate reply here is
Knight to E5
which has a threat of Knight to F3 but
all white has to know is just give this
check
so that it doesn't matter wherever the
King goes our next move is capturing the
queen and if you count the end result
White House Queen and three pawns
against bishop and Rook
but look at this pathetic rook in the
corner it will take ages to come out and
don't forget white king is completely
open so considering all this fact if you
look at the chess engine analysis here
it gives white a clearly upper hand
last but not least what to do against
the move Queen to C7
well this time around white has yet
another dazzling sacrifice
did you see it
congratulations if you find the move
Knight to D for high what a move
and I think after this however black
plays
if you look at the evolution it's
completely favoring the white
well there are a lot of variation
including some decline lines so I leave
it for you to research further however I
like to show you a model game which will
highlight how problematic this variation
is if black accept this piece
okay we are going to take back the pawn
with check so that black can't play
Bishop to E7 as Knight to F5 regain the
piece back with interest
so that is right out of the equation
that means black has to move the king
and after the accurate response King to
d8
white should continue with Bishop to G5
pinning down the night and if required
give blood some horrible Pawn structure
on the king's side
well in the game black avoid this by
playing Knight B to D7
after that I really like white approach
just look at this game guys as every
move create a important threats
white Kickstart with Knight to C6 this
Knight is way too dangerous so black
Chop It Off
after that Pawn Tech C6
well funny enough in the database black
has tried the move Knight to E5
highestly here but I think it's a
blunder as white can simply take it
as the Deep on his pin so nope the
accurate responses Knight to C5
whereupon why deliver this initiative
sequence
Bishop to E3 threat is Bishop capture C5
so black plays Knight to E6
now comes another nice move A4 threat is
spawn captures B5
so black neutralize this with B4
now come the third important thread A5
getting the queen
and I'm sure after a long thought black
played the move Rook to B8 which is in
fact the only good reply available here
where rather than grabbing the exchange
I really like White's play
he keeps generating the thread with
Queen to D3
attacking the weak bone
black plays Queen to C8 defending it now
comes Bishop to B6 Jack
kindly note that if King to E8 then C7
wins The Exchange
so black is obliged to block the check
with the Knight
now comes Queen to C4
well I really like White's approach in
this position
he has completely tied down black and
force him to play the only move difa
here
but as soon as this happened the game
become open as white rightly so take the
spawn so that the D file become open and
even blacks Desperado Rook takes B6
doesn't save the game as after Pawn
takes B6
finally when black took the bishop the
easiest move in the world Rook to Devon
and Queen to F5 has been played only way
to defend the Knight
but then C7 check King to C8 and
although in the game white plays Queen
to C6 I think the most accurate response
is
Queen captures A6 and after this there
is a mate in two guys
well if you want you can pause the video
and try it by yourself I am showing you
right now King to D7
Pawn promotion Queen check
King to D6 and now lovely
Pawn goes forward and deliver the chat
mate
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile tricks against
the Sicilian French radiation
you can literally use this line in the
tournament practice as it can be
occurred in three different Sicilian
variation
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care